[Applause]
is the spirit of
freedom is spirit of liberty
they don't understand in what country
and
in what what time do they leave they
don't speak with people in the same
language
they have already lost
i would give up if
was alone for sure i think so
maybe not
the people of belarus are daring to
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
dream
in city after city in their tens of
thousands
people from all walks of life and all
backgrounds
the very old two braving the pandemic
fed up with the leader that they've had
for too long and
inspired by the courage of a 37 year old
mother and housewife
who is taking on president alexander
lukashenko on behalf of her husband who
he's jailed
[Applause]
beside her are the wife and campaign
manager of two other presidential
candidates who were also barred from
running
one of them is in prison too the other
fled to moscow
[Music]
these three women are now standing as
one behind tikanovsky
to unite the ever-growing opposition to
president lukashenko's 26-year rule
[Applause]
[Music]
belarus has refused to give sky news
accreditation to cover the election
so we commissioned a filmmaker to
document their campaign
and the devotion which drives it to
their country
and the men whose mission they've taken
on everything i do
i do for him first of all for his
liberty for his freedom
because i like him so much i love my
children i love my husband and
i love all the russian people who
you know who want to be free in this
country who want to
to feel free to say anything they want
about
our government about anything it's just
freedom we have never known
you know
lukashenko is not expected to play fair
in the run-up to this weekend's vote his
security forces have been brutal
detaining or fining more than 1200
protesters
and targeting especially bloggers and
journalists
who has a well-known youtube channel was
thrown into jail on a pretext
after this woman refused to leave him
alone at a campaign event
so i'm indication
it makes you realize why belarus is
called europe's last dictatorship
foreign
has been a turning point galvanizing
civil society to step in where the state
would not
crowdsourcing supplies for hospitals
around the country
lukashenko too busy advocating vodka and
saunas as treatment as his people died
[Music]
if kovid burned his bridges with the
public he is rapidly burning them with
his nearest abroad too
in a strange incident last week 33
alleged mercenaries from the russian
private military company wagner
were arrested in a sanatorium outside
the capital minsk
the belarusian kgb said their suspicions
were raised because the group were not
drinking alcohol
lukashenko says they were sent to
ferment revolution
which moscow denies saying the russians
were just in transit
[Music]
commander
she's learned to campaign as she goes
remarkably successfully
but the stress is telling on her
[Applause]
it's an exhausting schedule plus there
have been anonymous phone calls
threatening her with jail
and that her children will be taken away
and put in an orphanage
a tactic the president has used on
opposition figures before
she's had to send them abroad to keep
them safe but even her ten-year-old
realizes that she is not
yesterday he sent me text
where he wrote mom i okay i'm so
pity for you and i'm afraid for you
and i realized somehow he understands
that what i'm doing it's rather
dangerous
her running mate veronica cepcalo has
also had to send her children away
we meet them in moscow on their first
sightseeing trip to the kremlin
valerie cepcallo is one of the
candidates barred from running for
president
he is a former ambassador to the united
states and a key figure in the
belarusian i.t
sector and he's holding on to what may
prove to be a vain hope
that there will be cracks within the
elites i hope
that the members of the local electorate
committee
and in general all the bureaucratic
apparatus and all these
law enforcement agencies they that they
will finally stand on the side of the
will of the people
it is a common refrain at the rallies
that the president has only three
percent support
[Applause]
even if it's more he will not win this
election without widespread
[Music]
much will depend on those brave enough
within the state bureaucracy
to stand up for democracy taking their
lead
from three brave women who won't let an
old-school autocrat
break their families or their country
[Music]
diana magnay sky news moscow
[Music]
you